foreign
do you know what the realm is
it's the Thousand Blades of aegon's
enemies a story we agreed to tell each
other over and
we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones and A
Song of Ice and Fire video in this video
I want to give my thoughts about
everything that has been happening
behind the scenes at HBO I will be
discussing all the recent developments
regarding HBO's Game of Thrones shows as
you all know there has been a lot of new
information releasing since last week
not only did House of the Dragons start
filming its second season but we also
found out HBO is developing several new
shows based on George RR Martin's A Song
of Ice and Fire all of this is obviously
very exciting for us Game of Thrones
fans now the first thing we heard was
HBO might be developing a new Game of
Thrones show about aegon the very first
king of the Targaryen Dynasty he's where
all the other aegons in A Song of Ice
and Fire get their name for those of you
who don't know this show would focus on
aegon in his Sister Wives vicenya in
rainey's as they conquered Westeros from
the backs of their dragons now shortly
after this only a few days later we
found out HBO made a full series order
for a show about the adventures of
Duncan egg the that means the first
season has already been given a green
light the new show will follow dunk who
was the future Lord commander of the
kingsguard sir Duncan the tall and egg
who was the Future King aegon Targaryen
roughly 90 years before the events in a
Game of Thrones now ever since we found
out HBO is making all these other shows
fans have been wondering what this means
for Jon Snow as you all know George RR
Martin confirmed HBO was also developing
a series about Jon Snow this would be
the first sequel series HBO is making
now this show would actually follow the
events of what happens after Game of
Thrones ended we would see what is
happening in Westeros after Daenerys
died bran became king Arya sailed West
and Jon Snow was exiled north of the
wall and I gotta be honest I'm still
very interested in the show in fact I
might want to see this show more than a
new series about aegon or Duncan egg now
don't get me wrong I would love watching
all those shows as well I'm very happy
HBO is still adapting A Song of Ice and
Fire however we already have a good idea
of how those shows will end what has me
very excited about a series about Jon
Snow is the unknown we don't know what
would happen in a show like that I also
still believe it would give HBO the most
success as well any show directly
connected to Game of Thrones and those
original characters will be a home run
for the network that's what we all know
best and that's what we fell in love
with the most it wouldn't only have to
focus on Jon Snow either as we all know
there are still a lot of our favorite
characters alive in Westeros sansa's
leading the north Arya is sailing west
of Westeros Yara is in the iron islands
and bran Sam Gilly Davos Brienne Tyrion
and many others are still living in
King's Landing we very well could see
all of them show up in a series about
Jon Snow and let's not forget canvara
still out there as well there's a lot of
fans still hoping she will resurrect
Daenerys after drogon brings her body to
volantis now I know it might be very
hard to get all these actors to sign
back up on for another Game of Thrones
show however a lot of them already said
they would the actors known as Arya
Samwell and Brienne already said they
would love to revisit Westeros again I
mean hell even Amelia had fun with the
idea of Daenerys coming back I think
just about all of them would join the
show if HBO threw a big enough bag of
money at them one of the first things
that leads me to believe HBO is still
making the Jon Snow series is based on
what George R Martin said himself during
his own announcement about the Duncan
egg show George R Martin said I see all
these stories on the internet about
other spin-offs being killed or
abandoned I have no idea where they get
this stuff and it just makes me shake my
head the nymeria show is still in
development and so is the sea snake show
we just had a great week on that one
working with the writers and there's
other shows still getting made both live
action and animated in this update he
had already discussed House of the
Dragon Duncan egg nymeria and the sea
snake so when he says HBO is still
making other live-action shows he's
referring to something else now one
option might be the new series about
aegon but another option could be the
series about Jon Snow remember it was
actually George RR Martin who confirmed
all the information about the Jon Snow
series about six months ago he was
actually the one who let us know kit
Harrington was working directly with his
own writers and directors at HBO so I do
think it is safe to assume they are
still making this show since no one has
said otherwise now the best evidence is
actually from Entertainment Weekly who
has a direct source inside HBO they've
actually had a great relationship with
HBO and Game of Thrones since the early
days of the show they're always the ones
who get the exclusive behind the scenes
access whenever they're making a new
season now when they broke the news
about the full series order for Duncan
egg they also revealed the Jon Snow show
is very close to getting a full series
order of its own this is what they
actually said after discussing it with
their HBO sores they said a number of
other Game of Thrones related shows are
in contention for a full series order
including a sea snake show and the kid
Harrington LED Jon Snow's spin-off a
series about aegon Targaryen and the
Conquering of Westeros was reportedly
discussed but sources clarified that
Entertainment Weekly that it's not
happening at this time time as you can
see their sources say HBO is not making
a show about aegon right now however the
Jon Snow series is still in contention
for a full series order that means we
might be finding out it's getting a
green light very soon now as I've always
said before since I first heard about
the news about six months ago I think
this would be HBO's best option the Jon
Snow show would be a massive success for
the network it would immediately bring
back every single Game of Thrones fan
because it would open up new options for
a different ending to the show if the
Jon Snow show begins right where we left
off after he was set north of the wall
then Game of Thrones isn't over we have
not seen the ending if they're still
writing what happens in the Jon Snow
series now they may never say it's Game
of Thrones season 9 but that's exactly
what it would be if we're starting right
where we left off with all the same
characters and storylines and that
sounds like it's exactly what they want
to do I mean kid Harrington did say so
himself during the fan convention he
said he wants to see how Jon Snow was
affected with the Fallout of stabbing
Daenerys Targaryen and having to live
his life back North of the wall he wants
to see how everything affected his
character I know I'm not the only one
who's very interested in seeing what
would happen next HBO if you're
listening do us fans a favor and get it
done we need a better ending than what
Dan and Dave gave us we all know the
internet would definitely break if you
released a statement announcing Game of
Thrones was coming back the fans are
waiting let me know what all of you
think about this down below do you still
think we're getting the Jon Snow show or
do you think it will never happen I want
to know what everyone thinks about this
as always I want to thank all of you for
watching the video I hope all of you
have a great day I will see you again
very soon bye
[Music]
thank you
foreign